[Musik]
[Gelächter]
richtiger echt billig alter leute ich
glaube wir hatten alle in unserer
schulzeit mal so diesen einen punkt wir
uns gedacht hamburg hat dieser eine
lehrer oder eine lehrerin fällt mir
schon gut so man stellt sich in seinem
eigenen kopf so vor was wäre wenn super
lässt sie wissen
dieses gedanken kino spielen meinetwegen
auch über ein paar tage am ende merkt
man halt auch dass man als künftiger
mensch so was natürlich nicht machen
kann
ja ja was soll ich sagen leute diesen
vernünftigen schluss gedanken dass man
ja so was eigentlich nicht machen kann
haben leider nicht alle menschen hier in
deutschland und so ist die hilfe der
folge auf klassenfahrt erwischt schüler
liebt seine lehrerin entstanden und ja
wir werden uns jetzt mal anschauen und
gucken wie es realistischerweise
aussehen würde wenn denn ein schüler
eine beziehung mit seiner lehrerin
anfängt
[Musik]
ok also haben wir so lehrern leute das
ist corinna 39 ihr gegenüber steht ihr
schüler bei 18 und ja was soll ich sagen
ich befürchte das ganze unheil wird
jetzt seinen lauf nehmen
da geht schon direkt los so ihr zimmer
das zimmer von der lehrerin ist so ganz
am ende von so einem langen gang ja und
er läuft auf ihr zimmer zu ja und ich
fragte was machst du hier ja ich musste
noch mal auf toilette müssen sie die
toilette die 200 meter in die andere
richtung es ja da musste ich bin
deswegen bin ich jetzt gerade bei ihrem
zimmer allein die vorstellung dass ich
immer zu ernsthaft diesen spruch bringt
und so erwartet dass die andere seite
das so sagt sie ach so ach du hast du
wirklich nicht so kann er steht so ja
also hier viel offensichtlicher kann man
nicht machen dass man was mit dem rücken
hält er hätte vielleicht sich noch so
kann er noch so fünf freunde engagieren
können diese rote pfeile halten die so
oft unseren rücken zeigen das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen auffälliger aber
das müsste also ja leute wir merken
schon kreis auf jeden fall keiner von
der schlauen sorte er läuft vollkommen
unnötig auf seine lehrerin zu nachdem er
ganz woanders auf toilette war und macht
das während er verbotenerweise eine
bierflasche in der hand hat brauchst du
musst nicht zum zimmer seiner lehrerin
laufen mit einer bierflasche der hand
okay du findest du also wirklich nicht
so schlau wirklich die frage also was
erwartet sich keiner von diesen sprüchen
sodass sie sagt ach so nur ein kleines
bier sagt doch gleich bist nur 37
natürlich erlaubt die regeln gelten
vereine
auch für dich gib mir die flasche und
auf dem zimmer und wenn ich dich noch
mal also ich glaube hatten wir schon
zwei spiele gehabt leute so wir können
festhalten dass kein nicht die hellste
kerze am tannenbaum ist glaube ich aber
scheinbar im hilf mir universum muss man
das auch nicht sein um mit der eigenen
lehrerin was anzufangen
ja ja muss los aber ich hätte vielleicht
vor waren sollen leute ab der stelle
beginnt glaube ich der ehren lose
partners videos okay gut ja ich hatte es
vielleicht kurz vergessen und ich hätte
vielleicht kurz die erwartungen an diese
folge hier das halt irgendwo was sinn
machen würde das vielleicht so ein
kleines detail auch nur sinn macht in
dieser ganzen masse an und sind die da
auf uns einprasselt aber nein die
lehrerin macht erstmal für entspannte
fünf sekunden mit bei der ganzen sache
macht auch mit dem rum und dann danach
spinnst du
[Musik]
der sowas will ich gar nicht sehen alter
kürze erinnern an dem schreiben heute
corinna 39 18
ja es ist so schlimm
also ich meine hilfe ist dafür bekannt
dass sie keine komplizierten handlungen
aufbauende leute aber wie stumpf ist das
bitte er vollkommen unvermittelt ohne
irgendwie zu flirten oder irgendwas
springt auch seine lehrerin drauf küsst
diesem 85 sekunden erst mit sagt dann
nein stopp und er dann so ja egal ich
probiere noch mal und dann macht somit
das natürlich realistisch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
eine echt wichtiger echt milter was ist
das für ein mensch
ok also corinna 39 ja die frau ist fast
40 okay die steht mit beiden beinen in
ihrem professionellen leben die hat ihr
studium durchgezogen
die hat ihr referendariat durchgezogen
um lehrer zu werden die hat als lehrerin
die sich etabliert an dieser schule und
dann ist so was ist das ein 18 jähriger
der mit mir aus starten will
scheiß auf meinen job scheiß auf mein
leben ich bin dabei das gibt mir in der
studio for you tube noch auf die idee
kommt dieses video aufgestellt youtube
ich war ich mach das nicht corinna ist
geschafft von ihrem eigenen verhalten
daran stadt davon zu rennen
corinna ist geschockt von ihrem eigenen
verhalten doch anstatt davonzurennen
sollte sie lieber noch einmal überdenken
ob es so eine gute idee war bei rtl2
mitzuspielen
ok also das dann schauen wir die ganze
klassenfahrt sind einfach drei schüler
in dieser klasse ok
drei stühle eine lehre ok ja ich hab
nicht passt was ich gerade gesagt ich
habe die ganze nacht an dich gedacht
okay okay sorry sorry das ist natürlich
ins trainer den ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen kann
du hast die ganze nacht da gelegen und
überlegt wie du deine eigene lehrerin
wieder sehen kannst ist ja nicht so dass
ihr mit drei schülern und einer lehrerin
auf klassenfahrt zeit und ihr
lehrerzimmer vermutlich einfach den gang
runter ist er leute er hat die ganze
nacht überlegt und er ist auch keine
idee gekommen wir sie hätte wieder sehen
können
mal ganz davon abgesehen dass er sie
jetzt gerade wieder sieht also ist der
nächste tag musste einfach nur warten
vorstellt wie das also darüber vor dass
wir wirklich im echten leben passiert
eine 39 jahre alte frau wissen wieviel
jahre lebenserfahrung sind es des
geisteskranken verkaufs und 18 jähriger
bis kopf und denkt sich so also die
finde ich ganz geil wahrscheinlich denkt
die lehrer nicht ahnt ja klar warum
nicht und du darfst niemals mit jemand
darüber reden sonst ist meine karriere
am ende und ich finde keinen job mehr
verspricht ist mir kein versprechen ja
ja ja ja ja ja ja also leute wenn eine
sache in diesem universum sicher ist
dann dass wenn ein 18 jähriger schüler
was mit einer lehrerin hat er ist am
nächsten tag was sage ich am nächsten
tag innerhalb der nächsten 30 minuten
nachdem es passiert ist der ganzen
schule erzählen wird innerhalb von 30
minuten weiß das ganze bundesland davon
bescheid
[Gelächter]
britta geräte diese frau hat mich ein
bisschen also ich glaube zu wissen wie
mir das vorstellen wenn wir das zuvor so
gott schafft so die menschen und hat so
ein gewisses niveau an stil punkten das
er allen geben könnten bei ihr ist
einfach so dass kein eigener wille so
auf dass nicht nur das negativbeispiel
wieder hier also nee wir lassen uns
jetzt wenigstens jetzt nimmt sie an der
hand
ich habe alles getan was ich hätte
machen können also er hat mich an der
hand angefasst was soll ich jetzt machen
ja perfekt corinna super wirklich eine
runde applaus wird diese frau ja der
gute vorsatz nichts mit dem eigenen
18-jährigen schüler anzufangen hat an
der stelle glaube ich tendenziell eher
nicht so lange halten
du hast das ist das lehrerin nummer zwei
ja also haben wir zwei lehrerinnen drei
schüler a ja genau
zu den verstand verloren
corinna die gerade eben noch rechts im
zelt war steht auf einmal links und die
lehrer die andere lehrerin kommt von
rechts wo hat denn teleportiert oder wie
[Gelächter]
immer das war dann nicht nur die
richtung einfach nur die grobe
himmelsrichtung aus der die charaktere
ins bild reinlaufen nicht mal das passt
ja aber diese sachen leute anders nach
für corinna die wurde jetzt einfach beim
teleportieren at habt mal gucken was die
anderen dazu sagen wir sehen wirklich
wie aus corinna quasi die emotionen
herausbrechen auf einmal erkennt sie hat
mein leben ist am arsch und auf gar
keinen fall wirkt es sehr befremdlich
wie sie hier schauspieler dass man sie
noch einen platz abgeben das ist
wirklich dafür sollte es eigentlich ein
ausgang geben leute
das irgendwann mein gesichtsausdruck
wenn ich mir für euch wieder neues hilfe
video anschauen muss dann springt es
wird ein bisschen sie sind wieder zurück
in der schule und was jetzt passiert wer
soll uns hier sehen hier mitten auf der
straße
jeder der da wohnt also das ist doch
oder hört sie sich nicht an der stelle
vielen lieben dank an diese fremde
ältere frau mit der leicht merkwürdigen
frisur
genau das war auch gerade mein gedanke
und ja weil das auch die letzte szene
dieser hilfe folge ist möchte ich mit
ihr könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren wir
euch die folge gefallen hat schreibt mir
gerne die kommentare was wir von dieser
sehr hochwertige produktion haltet und
schalte beim nächste mal wieder einig
kürzere augen bis dann macht's gut